four Ukrainian children have been freed
by Russia and have now been reunited
with their families the children the
youngest of which is only two years old
were released after Qatar acted as a
mediator the group passed through
qatar's Embassy in Moscow before leaving
Russia Zayn BVI is in key for us Zayn
there's there's lots of context around
this and you'll I know you'll get to
that in a moment but I want you to start
with just the facts run us through what
happened as you know
it
absolutely now according to what we're
hearing reports from the CES as well as
here in keev is that uh Doha has been
involved in talks between Moscow and
keev secret talks uh that have been
going on for many months but even as
early as July Ukraine's prime minister
Dennis shamal did did hint that Kaur was
involved in a number of issues speaking
after a meeting with Ka diplomats in
July he said cut was assisting in many
issues especially the repatriation of
children and that seems to have uh had
some success now in terms of actual
numbers since the beginning of this war
400 children have been returned from
Russian hell territory but Ukraine has
identified 20,000 children that have
gone missing or have been held they say
illegally uh by Russian forces or by
Russia since this War Began now the
children were hearing of Friday there
was one child return now three more
between the ages of uh 2 9 and 17 being
repatriated certainly success in these
dialogues but uh just a drop in the
bucket so far to that context then
there's an International arrest warrant
out on the Russian president I mean some
of our viewers may have forgotten but
this is Major News International arrest
warrant out against Vladimir Putin for
this for the transfer the forced
transfer of Ukrainian children from
Ukraine to
Russia as this is an incredibly primary
issue for the Ukrainian government
government for the Armed Forces for the
people of Ukraine there's even a March
in the main Square later today for
people calling on the Ukrainian
government to do more to have those
children to have missing people in
general found and repatriated to Ukraine
it is a major uh issue for people in
terms of the context of this war and
kaur's role in this is is becoming more
highlighted it has become a bit of a a
diplomatic a global diplomacy Hub an
important partner in these kinds of
things cut officials will be
accompanying children
throughout the process from when they
are handed over by the Russians to cutri
authorities they then accompany them
either first to Doha or possibly to the
borders uh like Estonia or bellarus
there's even a humanitarian Corridor
directly connected at the border between
Russia and Ukraine in the sui region and
C officials will be with these children
along the way the entire uh process now
Cur has become an important partner in a
number of different uh conflicts
globally it was an important diplomatic
partner in the war in Afghanistan it has
negotiated deals between the United
States and Iran it is an active
negotiator between all parties in the
ongoing Gaza War at the moment and this
uh deal between Moscow and keev
certainly a bit of good news in the
midst of this war all right Zayn basravi
reporting from keev on that thank you
very much Zane